what's up everyone I'm Matthew and Sina
and today I'm joined by a very special
guest patrulla over on titus you've seen
around the show before and today we're
gonna review your guys's portfolio so
we're gonna break down your portfolio's
give you guys feedback so that you can
go out there and crush it so just in
case you don't know who I am I'm Matthew
and Cena I'm gonna create a professional
now for about 15 years been a creative
director at blind for the past eight
years and prior to that I've been
freelancing for about seven years so
I've been on both sides of the table
both as someone who's trying to get a
job and get work as well as hiring staff
and freelancers and patrulla I've been a
graphic designer and an educator for
over 25 years and I have really designed
business in Los Angeles and I've been
teaching at Art Center College of Design
and my role there is to help students
get ready for what's going to be
expected of them both creatively and
professionally and I'm really happy that
matt's asked me to come today because
one of the courses I teach us is
specifically on developing your
portfolio before we dig into the
particular portfolios I just wanted to
give you guys a framework of how we're
going to be looking at your portfolios
and how we're going to be measuring them
so for me I'm particularly looking for
three specific things one is the first
impression so when I land on your site
do I know right away what it is that you
do and is it presented in a professional
way number two is it consistent do you
have at least three to five examples of
consistently good work and is it
presented again professionally and solid
is there clarity and context so when I
dig into each of your projects do I know
what the project is about what the
challenges and goals were and what your
particular role on this was what was
your POV on this right because I'm
mostly on the side of hiring people I
make my decisions right away so when I
look at portfolios I usually have about
like 10 or 15 seconds before I decide
whether or not I want to spend more time
on that portfolio or just move on
because usually just like this episode
we get hundreds of entries for a
particular position and then patrulla I
don't know I know you work at Art Center
and you help students work on their
portfolios are there anything else that
you look
for in terms of ways that you can tag
arrays or break down somebody's
portfolio I think what I'm looking for
is to make sure that when somebody like
Matt is seeing the portfolio he's really
aware of your uniqueness and that you're
giving him a context in which to take a
look at your work it's not just here's
my work it's here some of my goals these
are the things I like to do so he can
actually start placing you and one more
another part of his company I think
without that context what can happen is
the portfolio is just viewed in a
decorative visual way where they are
actually hiring the person that has the
ideas and understanding of the problem
so I want to I'm gonna be giving a lot
of input as to how to present things
beyond just the imagery that will appeal
to either someone like Matthew in a
design consultancy or for a recruitment
manager at a company like Nike so what
are they looking for that's different
from something that Matt would be
looking for right well I think we could
start digging into the portfolios so
first up we have Harsha Lani you know
I'm gonna butcher all of your names I'm
gonna apologize for that ahead of time
his goal is to get freelance work and a
little about um hi I am harsh Jelani
from India
I am paper and identity and packaging
designer and I'm working as a freelancer
for the past one year my portfolio is a
mix of personal and client work so let's
jump in here so first impressions well
my first impression is Behance is really
good at the visuals so I'm just having a
little bit of difficulty understanding
whether harsh is looking for work
internationally whether he's looking for
work specifically in India whether he's
looking to work in smaller with smaller
businesses or larger businesses there's
a lot of questions about context Behance
gives you an opportunity here's the
about me porn but he's pretty much just
saying the same the same thing because
and I would really want to know I'm
interested in form design that would be
interesting cuz he's doing packaging I'm
interested specifically in beverage
industry which seems like what he's
doing apparel beverage industry because
I'm looking to know what his expertise
is and I'm just not positive yet how to
place him my first impression visuals
very nice and clean nice and colorful so
already it's a delight to look at so if
we were to click into one of these this
is for your branding and packaging so we
land on this thing and we see a couple
of the examples here it looks like
packaging mock-ups this would be helpful
Matthew if he let me know what this was
yeah well here we go from the Himalayas
your was born as a search of pure Indian
flavors blended with energy and health
so that's about the product but it's not
about what you've worked on on this
project so as patrulla has been saying
there's no context for this job at all
for this project so it's all visuals
it's pure visuals and if I'm looking
specifically for a packaging designer
then it's maybe this will work okay but
the fact that you know it doesn't say
what was the brief for the project what
were the challenges and the goals and
then what was your unique solution on
this thing the kind of thing I would
want to hear is is it a rebrand does
this project exist and he's rebranding
it mm-hmm what is he trying to do that's
differentiating it from other kinds of
of project products in in the let's say
in the supermarket aisles it's a mess
right right so I don't see it I see how
it is the same or different or maybe and
the other thing that is a little
confusing to me
it's his Cola and lime mm-hmm and I
don't know that that's pure Indian
flavors with energy and health I don't I
don't quite understand the relationship
of that statement to Cola and lime so
there's a little bit of a disconnect
here for me in regards to again the
context he is giving me and also on that
I always like to know whether this is a
real project or not he stated that he
has been freelancing is this a freelance
project or is this one of the projects
that he's done independently let me ask
you why do you think that that's
important from your POV because doing
work for clients is much more
challenging
doing work for yourself so if he
actually produced this for a real client
I would be really impressed right if
he's producing this for himself I'm
impressed but not quite as much right
because this kind of you know this is
this is a good project but it's really
impressive if he actually if this
thing's out on the market right so I
think for me I don't really care if it's
a real project or not but because I have
no context in terms of what you actually
designed what challenges did you solve
so whether that's fictitious or not like
I need to know that as somebody who's
hiring a designer because all design is
is problem-solving its visual
communication and problem-solving so
because we only have the visuals here I
have no idea if you've actually solved
the problem or not so the context that
patrulla was talking about what we
normally call like a competitive audit
if this is packaging for a beverage
product on the shelf how does this stand
out was that one of the challenges that
needs to stand out there on the shelf
look does it need to communicate a
particular thing I don't know any of
these things because there's no context
on the website so regardless if it's a
real client project or not and client
projects yes can be a lot more difficult
all I want to know is just how you think
and it's not represented here let's look
at another project
you I'm kind of drawn to this coffee
thing I love coffee so neuro coffee so
again he's I think he's just writing
about the product but not necessarily
about his role in the project again
beautiful images I love seeing the
contextual stuff these overhead shots
love seeing the coffee just cut in
between here because it just helps give
the context of where this product might
be placed and kind of like the
production value or level of clientele
that this might attract because this
definitely would attract me as being a
an avid coffee drinker so I want to give
my impression of harsh okay just by what
I'm seeing here I believe that he's a
very competent designer I believe that
he has a really high skill level in
regards to attention to detail that's
showing up in both the way that his
mock-ups look and how he's very very
careful about these things i I'm really
confident about his design skills and
his ability to understand this
particular market I like the coffee the
beverage so if I had a project like that
I would really feel like he would be a
great designer to work with but I also
want more information because I'm gonna
be working with him giving him a brief
he's gonna be responding I wish there
was something that showed me a little
bit more process so I could see how he
works something that helps me know how
he researches I believe that by the
quality of the work that I see here he
does this right I just need to see it
right I was gonna say it looks
professionally presented right so that's
that's well done but we as somebody who
might hire him I have no idea how this
person works and that's scary
because now it looks like a risk yes and
people hire the least risky option right
and so when I look at this it looks
beautiful but I might be taking a risk
because I don't know how you work if I
were to give you the real creative brief
from a client I have no idea how your
thought process is how you might go
about solving that challenge to get to a
design solution here that's well thought
out I'm happy that you brought that out
when I'm talking to students about
putting a portfolio together I say okay
the problem to solve is and they all
think it's about something else and I
say the problem to solve is to instill
trust because hiring a designer is a
frightening thing there's so much we
don't know and especially when it comes
to us from another country we like the
work we're just not sure about one thing
or another
the time difference I mean there's just
so many things if harsh let me know that
he was working outside of of India too
and since and he's done freelance work
let's say in the US all the sudden I've
got some more trust I know
reddit he's ok with time differences and
he can handle that so just your job is
to instill trust right if I were to land
on your site as a potential employer if
I'm looking for somebody to do branding
and packaging I would stay and invest
and dig deeper to find out more but
because I don't have more of that
contextual information I would probably
bouncer put you a little bit lower on my
priority list on who I might hire versus
somebody who's very good at describing
their work describing the context in
which I'm viewing the work in I would
prioritize those people over over harsh
but in terms of technical it's all there
ok shall we move on let's do it right
now we'll look at the portfolio of a
Rohit Raj this person's goal is to get
freelance work and synopsis is I am a
self-taught graphic designer that works
on freelance projects currently I work
on branding logo design projects and now
I'm looking to go more deep as a brand
strategist to solve problems better
thank you for context yes so now we know
how to evaluate this portfolio right so
just by that it's telling me that I'm I
will find that here correct right that's
your expectations expectation has been
set now it has to follow through and it
also tells me that Rho heat wants to be
a little bit higher up in the food chain
okay so he might not be the designer
is just doing all the work he's the
designer that I can depend on as more of
a senior designer or an art director
versus just a designer that's where I
think I'm placing him now
right okay so now that that's our
expectations first impressions when we
land on this thing I mean I think the
visuals are pretty simple they're
straightforward I have a very high
expectation of you Rho Heat
when you see projects in a specific
order do you always click on the first
one first my assumption is that the top
left is the best project that's the
premium real estate right there okay so
I'm assuming that this person has put
their best project in the top left
wherever this exists okay yeah so I'm
gonna click here first removing
communication barrier open-book forget
this woman who's reading a six-tier book
and look so there's contact hey let's
read this okay the mission open book is
an English teaching agency in Japan it's
looking forward to influencing people to
learn English and remove communication
barriers among them so Medellin spelling
punctuation like little things in there
if that's the goal so I just need to say
spelling errors will eliminate you
immediately as a candidate that's it
should we move on what why is that why
is that because as a creative director I
need to trust you that you can look at
your own work and you can spell check
your own work because we've got we're
communication designers so we're dealing
with copy all the time and I can't have
that nagging feeling that you're going
to put client work out into the world
that has spelling errors in it there are
so many ways easy ways to spellcheck
this is a problem right now the issue
here is the word barrier is spelled
correctly right so this wouldn't
necessarily be picked up by a spellcheck
but it would be picked up in let's say
Microsoft Word as a grammar error right
or grammerly any of these things where
they're looking at grammar yeah and I
just I cannot say this enough creative
directors need you
to have this stuff handled and if you
find that this is a difficult thing for
you you've got to have someone who helps
you that you can trust because we need
to trust you right okay so so it's all
about trust it's all about trust and you
don't want these little things to add up
and erode the trust right so service is
brand identity brand strategy research
on target audience this is great I love
the context outcome after understanding
the inside of the agency we developed
the audience personas that targeted the
people interested in learning a second
language and also gave a brand refresh
to increase brand loyalty okay I want to
stop and say that there's a we here and
I don't know who we are
is this a team project if so what is his
role in the team right so again I love
the context but you've got to make sure
the context is clear right okay so the
impact after the launch of the fresh
identity more than 100 people visited
the website and around 20 to 25 people
registered for the class anyone
yay so I love this because what even
though I haven't really seen much of the
design yet I am very clear on what the
challenge was and what your impact was
based off of this project and that's
more important than the actual form of
the design right it's more about the
function its function first has to work
before it can be beautiful and you know
so when I read this stuff it gives me
context knowing that you've thought
through a problem and that everything I
will look at is moving towards
accomplishing that goal so important
keywords so they're highlighting some of
the key words English friendly
publishing world peace of this kind of
like a brainstorm the process move board
and sketches can we go into any of those
it's I don't think so not and yeah well
kind of okay because it especially with
the sketches I'm just having a hard time
see
yeah I think if you're gonna throw them
in there show them right don't make it
so small just a zoom in on one or a
couple in there so that we might see it
or talk about that yeah and I think the
mood board is slightly disconnected with
the key words
I'd like to actually see the key words
and the mood board because those are
things that supposedly influence one
another and that will help me to see
them you want to connect the ideas like
if this is his brainstorm right here how
do the words influence the thought
process of what's coming out visually
right so sketches are taken out open
books helps English language to various
size industries and schools in Japan
it's beneficial to have knowledge in a
global language to remove communication
barrier and help them work or move it
again I feel like this is a little bit
of a missed opportunity here because it
feels like it's more talking about the
project in a big way instead of now that
we're in it now that we've gone down
further on the page what was your
thought process in connecting the words
that brainstorm at the challenge into
what you've highlighted here what I
would expect to see here mm-hmm
is that something has been selected and
why because this is a detail and so I
would want to know about that detail but
I do like that he's at least doing this
if there was a way that he could even
circle the things on the mood board that
influenced the sketches that then
becomes here okay
hey open book so I'm assuming that's
like the cover and the logo now he's
talking more about the process it took
me more than two weeks to research and
create a customer persona talk to a
bunch of employers and instead of asking
whether they're interested in learning
English we ask them whether they're
interested in learning a second language
and if yes what's stopping them so man I
thought this is gonna be a little bit
more about the I don't know I'm a little
confused when I read this stuff
yeah for example I think it could be
that I would want you to tell me what
these forms mean I make assumptions
about what these forms mean right but
and it might seem obvious to you because
you're the creator but having you be
able to articulate why you're using blue
and red what the star represents why
there are two forms there right and you
know this the way that the the the Hat
is working it feels a little awkward I
think visually there's there's some
design issues with the logo I'm assuming
this is the logo that was developed here
but aside from that I think again yeah
giving some context as to how did we
arrive at this mark the thing that I
really like that he's done is he's put a
human hand in here he's giving me some
sense of scale a lot of times especially
with dimensional objects books packaging
um I I don't know if you know I know
what this is because it's a pen but but
sometimes I'll see things and I have no
idea if that thing's this big or this
small so scale especially when you're
dealing with virtual kinds of
presentations is crucial it is that
scale important because of the fidelity
of the mark in different contexts Azure
what is the I like scale because these
things are for humans and I'd like to
see humans interacting with them
and I also judge graphic design success
by the relative size of things you know
with that without that hand this book
could be tiny and that might be why the
logo is so large the logo seems quite
large here and it's still a little
confusing as to what's inside that book
as a book cover right I'm actually
struggling with it right okay let's keep
going so I don't know what this is it
looks like it's a quote from Nelson
Mandela but I don't have no context like
what is what are we looking at here and
that's you can see the difference here
of scale we have no idea if that's the
size of a business card I'm assuming
actually this card you are in terms of
the scale I would say that's probably a
page in that book I see but I don't know
that right what I would recommend for
this designer is that make the
information he's got on here slightly
more condensed but then add how the
design did that how his choices correct
the design choices he made then are
consistent with his findings as a person
who does research right that's a really
good point and I think that was the
thing I wasn't able to articulate or
earlier why I was confused because he's
giving you contextual information and
he's telling you here's the problem but
he's not telling you how he arrived at
the solution on the other side so he's
just telling this part and I think
that's just a little bit of a missed
opportunity but we kind of know why
because he's trying to really emphasize
his brand strategy right aspect right
something but even with brand strategy
you're recommending solutions right a
designer he's the designer and he's the
brand strategist I think I'm not sure
because he's got that word we write so
maybe he on this project didn't do the
design mm-hmm
maybe he just did the brand strategy and
someone else did the design right okay
so that's the end of this project so I
want to say that I think the context
could use work but it's helpful at least
you know going from your initial
submission into this website knowing
that you want to do brand strategy
it helps me frame and understand the
work from a very particular lens now
that one we got in
I think they're just a bunch of spelling
things a little bit of connecting the
dots in terms of what you thought of and
how you've come up with a unique
solution those are the things that are
lacking right now let's do one of the
last projects I'm always interested in
what they determine is last
so this one is branding for a Daily Show
for a Daily Show or The Daily Show okay
so I made a trip tip date owed a tip
sorry date tip on what does it say rs
square media so now when we were just
crazy
although the Gothic there's no context
at all for this woman
brand-new for today so that's it that's
the whole project so what someone will
do when they see this is they will
evaluate it decoratively so I'm I'm now
taking a look at well you know I'm
looking at the kerning I'm looking at at
the the forms and the relationship with
the forms like I'm just I'm looking at
it from a pure visual point of view I
don't like those type those fonts
together mm-hmm I don't think this is
working very well at all as a billboard
because it's hard to read even when we
can we have it so clearly here I can't
imagine being a car flying by right
there and actually understanding
anything whatsoever about this project
so it's a great point so when we were
coming in here we were looking at it
with a particular frame of mind and now
that there's no context or story now we
revert back to well does it look pretty
does it look good are we just looking at
aesthetically and you pointed out
there's some contrast issues in here
even even with us parked on this I had a
hard time reading r-square underscore
media so that's a very difficult
typeface if that's going to be it's not
a typeface to use on a billboard or know
the environmental signage so Rho Heat I
think there's a there's a bit of work to
do you are a good designer and it's just
a matter of figuring out
more about communicating the things you
want people to understand both about you
as a designer and the strategy I'm
really appreciative that you showed us
your process but I want you to show it
to us better and take us through it
what happened happens here is that
you're you've got to in essence
substitute for being sitting next to
somebody and showing them that work you
wouldn't just go here Matt here take a
look and you'd bring it right you need
to guide you then through the guidance
is super important connect the dots for
us have a sense of empathy that we are
afraid we don't know you we are afraid
to hire somebody we don't know it help
us by by getting this organized because
I think you do
terrific work all right let's move on to
the next person so let's look at the
portfolio of Kevin Lawrence Kevin
Lawrence's goal is to get a job I'm
assuming that's an in-house position and
let's read about him I'm a designer from
Scotland my career has been mostly as an
in-house designer and I hope to get a
job at an agency or web agency my work
is a mixture of in-house freelance and
personal projects my work is mainly web
design however a I have a strong
background in print design - it sounds
like this person is on a kind of
transition in a transition have done
some development and then some design
work as well so just by the context that
Kevin's given us mm-hmm I know that this
work has probably been more difficult
work because he's dealing with clients
especially in-house so I'm looking at
this now really differently than if he
was just graduating from school and he
had all these self initiated projects so
you know this is it's it's not even
comparable to some of the ones that we
had seen so first impressions I mean I
like the big bold images here these are
helpful
nice little snappy animation on these
things so this is fun let's click on
this top left because it I always assume
that this is the favorite team J
physique founder of team
Zeke Jo Parrish approached me several
years ago to work on his first website
this initial website shortly grew out
its Houston he started to expand his
business as the business grew I was
tasked with creating team J physique
online as well as showcasing the new
online coaches that had joined the team
this new website required a full members
area and that clients and paid members
could access remotely over the course of
six months I worked very closely with Jo
to help reach his vision to become
Scotland's number one online body
composition consultancy team Wow and
then the process this is kind of cool to
outline this discovery research
prototype design build test and then and
went live and his the clients
highlighted here the services branding
and web design so in terms of context
this is awesome this is great at first
glance it gives me a peek into what the
challenge was even feels a little
personal I I get the sense that you know
Jo Parrish for whatever reason or maybe
just the way that it's written it feels
very personal so I'm kind of drawn in a
little bit to understand okay now show
me how did you solve this this challenge
as we go here so I'm assuming this is
the logo the mark for it again probably
need a little context maybe on one of
these pages on the top left it could say
logo design colors and type it just
looks like it's all a design system and
this is the website
okay so now he's starting to show off
some of the features for the website
one of the biggest challenges in website
design is is the quality of the content
that you're working with so what
influence you had in that whether maybe
you were helping them ride it or where
you are working with a writer either one
is fine I just I always like to know and
I'm assuming this is a wireframe so
again a little context because I like
the overview at the very top where it
gives me the broad overview of what the
project is but as we scroll down
something you need to still guide the
viewer on the thought process at the
evolution on where you started and where
you're getting to or give context for
what each of these pieces are because
I'm gonna start inventing my own story
about what these things are and you may
or may not like it if you could even
highlight two features this website is
going to do this because of this reason
that we found it or the app unlike the
website the app does this because I I
really like to know how you've leveraged
the ability of these different media
types to convey the brand helps me know
that you understand the attributes as
you go from social media to app
development to signage these are all
different media types and you
understanding the affordances of that
media type gives me a lot of confidence
in you right and I think to that point
for me I'm just more interested in if I
look at the process upfront here it's a
discovery research prototype so these
things makes me feel like you had spent
some time understanding the user the
goals of the business and how that
aligns into what the visual result is
here at the end both as a website and
identity so the thing that I don't know
is how did you arrive at the solution
because what I get is the overview here
and then straight to the solution this
is just all solution but it doesn't tell
me what were some of the decisions that
you have made
you get here because there were a couple
things that you highlighted let's see
the goal was to showcase the new online
coaches he had that joined the team and
required some kind of login area for
full members and clients so I mean I
have to go back up there to understand
that maybe this that it's this area but
we don't know right it would be nice if
it was just highlighted here captions
just small caption mall captions to
highlight the coaches we use this type
of directed photography here and we're
showing the logo in context of the
trainer right so those are little things
that if you just add these little tweaks
it will help me as I'm scrolling down
because by the time I'm all the way down
at the bottom of the page I forgot what
I'm looking at so just reminding me
every point let's take a look at him
talking about himself the Disciplinary
designer with nine years of experience
digital design marketing I get geeky
about creative stuff we'll jump at the
chance to scuba dive and in another life
I would travel the world practicing
jiu-jitsu I really like this it's
concise it's friendly if you could add
Kevin in this that you're really looking
forward to taking the understanding that
you've gathered from working in house to
be able to work when outside
consultancies if there could be
something that tells me that you now are
really excited about broadening your
base of client that might entice me more
to understand oh okay this guy is really
ready and there are certain things that
you're gonna learn from an in-house
process that I think are going to be
crucial to those brand consultancies
you're going to have a view of projects
and process internally that we don't so
you got to help us know the value of you
beyond just a designer well because his
goal is to go work in how some right to
go at an agency or web agency but when
he goes from in-house to an agency I
mean he's gonna have some insight about
how to get projects approved what some
of the processes are that kind of thing
right yeah I think this is a good about
statement but if he wants that goal some
that needs to be clear so you're saying
that he should have some essence of what
his goal is rather than just talking
about him and the present tense in the
past maybe this is okay for the website
because he might still want to consider
some in-house work but if he did a cover
letter that gives somebody then access
to the site in that cover letter he can
be only specific about what his goals
are somehow I need to know that
mm-hmm let's take another look at her
another project
okay so I'm gonna click on this flesh up
I just clicked on it because it was
bright and colorful and it had an
interesting markup flash up when I
arrived at CLG they had begun using a
loyalty card for several years giving
customers discounts and deals at the
various venues I suggested that this
loyalty system should be revised as to
so as to keep up to date with the
advances in mobile technology I
suggested that the company switch over
to an app in order to appear more modern
while retaining the loyalty point system
for customers okay
go stop there okay empathy mm-hmm I have
no idea what CLG is right I guess that's
the client the client is CLG but I think
I don't know what it is
CLG is a it can be super simple right I
flash up doesn't really tell me anything
CLG like there no context personally if
I'm in a hurry I will click off of this
project right sorry because it's like if
you are a designer lacking empathy
you're not going to be able to do your
job very well
okay browsing events access to special
offers and booking a table or function
or some of the key elements when
designing and developing the app for CLG
user experience and functionality were
considered at very early stages and
throughout the build process I work
closely with development a development
firm to progress design ideas and
functionality in line with what was
achievable from a developer standpoint
it's the same thing that process is
outlined here you know one little tip
that I would say Kevin when you're doing
these overviews it could be good to just
break it down by overview challenge in
goal just for for us like for me I'm
reading it out loud for the sake of the
audience but in real life I would not
read this much you know I just need the
bullet points and I kind of assess very
visually so I would be scrolling through
this very quickly because I wouldn't
spend that much time to actually read
this stuff
okay so now we're on sketches some brand
identity I always like to know why I
appreciate that you're telling me all
these formulas for your colors but I
find that much less informative than why
those colors were chosen right and the
relationship of those colors to CLG
whatever CLG is correct I I'm the same
way again just context just dig in a
little bit deeper like why were these
chosen and what do they mean for the
brand so a little bit of story goes a
long way otherwise might as well not
show this stuff yeah
and then some wireframes so you scan a
QR code and then you gain points I guess
then these are screens of the still not
produced to have any idea what CLG is I
have no idea what CLG is so without
knowing what CLG is or does
I can't evaluate this at all right okay
sorry yeah I mean the visuals are the
visuals are very nice as we're getting
through this like I like these mock-ups
and these webpages and the colors from a
visual standpoint we revert to that
right because it's all we can evaluate
it on otherwise I have no way of
understanding like you said if one of
the things that designers believe is
that this work speaks for itself and I I
don't believe that's the case at all I
think that because you know it so well
you think it speaks for itself but it
took you a really long time to
understand it and you had to understand
it deeply to be able to design with it
so I think that's a kind of a cop-out I
hear it a lot from young designers like
I just want the visuals up people just
the the work speaks for itself no it
does not you speaking for your work is
really important to me if I'm gonna hire
you and if Matt's gonna hire you he
needs you to be able to explain your
work really clearly to either us the
team or outside as clients he has to
have enough confidence that he can take
you on a client meeting and that you
could actually explain your work and
even though the clients might understand
it because they understand their company
they need to know why the designer was
so important in the development of this
you could it's not it's kind of like you
gotta prove your worth you have to have
a fluency about the ability to speak
about the creative process and its
importance no I think that's really good
because as we continue down this path
where there are more and more designers
out there who are very competent
technically right we're getting there
were the tools are becoming easier to
make beautiful things the difference
between you and someone else is the
value you might bring to a particular
client or a company that
you work for so I think what patrulla
said there is like what did you bring to
the table that might be helpful to this
particular situation and the more you
can highlight that the more you can tell
that story as you're as you guys are
building your portfolio pieces and case
studies is gonna be more helpful for me
so if I'm hiring you're evaluating you I
might know that what value you might
bring to me okay another thing for you
Kevin is you're calling your company
armored digital which is fine and what I
assume is that you've got a company so
my company or met or blind or the future
would be hiring armored digital not you
because he's kind of saying I'm a I'm a
design firm mm-hmm so it's a little
awkward if I'm gonna then if you want to
actually come and work with Matt as an
employee mm-hmm because he's gonna he
would be hiring Kevin Lawrence not
Armour digital so there's a little does
that make sense yeah yeah so your
perception of him is that this is a he's
put his he's put a commitment that he is
now a studio and I would be hiring a
studio right and I don't know that
that's what he's doing because he said
his goals were different than that to
that point your perception is that it
feels like he has he's committed to
video to to his own firm which is called
armor digital mm-hm and I would not
think he was up for being hired so the
way to fix that is that this would say
Kevin Lawrence mm-hmm web web specialist
you know he can even give himself a
title so you know I'm on the fence on
that thing I don't necessarily fully
agree with that I don't mind if people
go buy an aka but the perception which I
share with you is that this is a studio
and that it's not an individual so it
doesn't feel like you're right it's it's
like we're competing now right we're at
the same level instead of hiring a
potential staff person here you know
it's so there is a disconnect there but
I don't mind if somebody uses an aka
where it's not there at their name um I
want to comment on photo
I'm not criticizing Kevin looks I'd like
to make sure that people understand the
perception of the photos what do you
think about Kevin what information does
that photograph of Kevin give you he's a
guy that likes to smile and he's he
seems super pleasant and nice to work
with yeah he does and he's got a he's in
a work environment he seems early eager
smart for some reason he looks like he
would really listen to me and care what
I had to say and he looks like he's a
bit more mature he said he's nine years
of experience so that helps me to just
the idea of some life experience under
his belt I'm really positive like I'm
feeling very much like he's a peer of
mine okay let's go to contact cuz that's
something you were very much wanting to
you you had come easy to contact yeah
that was what's been easy to contact
yeah his emails right here and then he
has a form I don't think that you need
both but that's alright so when I when I
land on here if I assume that the work
is good I can see the work is great we
did a little bit of about I think this
is one area where we can dig in a little
bit deeper like you were saying like
what are some of his goals and he could
really expand here because in the footer
actually there's more information about
them in the footer than there is on his
about me page right so these are all
favorite food favorite place inspired by
Krishna to your coffee coffee all the
way by the way being inspired by Christo
is terrific because it tells me that you
actually care about the business of
design and I really care that good
designers care about the business of
design so and you know a level of
self-improvement I think that was a good
move so assuming I go through all of
this and now I'm ready to contact Kevin
pretty clear to me shows all the places
where I can find him if I wanted to dig
in deeper so this is pretty
straightforward yeah I don't I don't
care for these forms I want to make it
as easy for people to contact you as
possible so I think putting up an email
is great I I think also he could give me
a resume and that resume if it's
that I'm linked to I might want a phone
number on there just to have more
ability to quickly get in touch I don't
like to fill out forms and send them at
all I don't I don't know I'd be really
curious what the statistics are about
how many people actually use this they
appear a lot in portfolio site templates
as an option but I this is it yeah I'm
kind of the same way I would rather have
an email address to contact somebody
directly and then continue the
conversation they're the only reason I
would see the need for a contact form is
maybe you do different things and you
have different dropdowns here to say I'm
getting in touch for and then there's a
subject that might help sort it on the
backend but that's usually for people
who is like if you have a business which
assume are more digital is is that you
need a way to sort and vet clients but
if you're doing that as a freelancer it
kind of doesn't make sense unless you're
just getting emails like 20 potential
leads a day and then you need some way
to pre-vet the clients and that's when
you would put up a contact form some
information maybe some like minimum
level of the engagement but that's only
when you're crazy busy and you need to
choose some people away and put a wall
up and I wouldn't do it Kevin really
good work let's let's highlight in recap
so some of the things me and patrulla
were debating whether or not you should
use your real name or a fictitious name
for a studio regardless it I I'm okay
with using an aka
but the thing is the perception is that
you're a studio so it doesn't seem like
I could hire you to be an in-house staff
person so that's number one that I feel
like is going against your goal right
now number two as we look at each of
your project breakdowns just giving us a
little bit more of a guided step by step
as we're scrolling down through these
because by the time we get to the bottom
we forgot what was at the top so just
using captions or just breaking up your
explanation and guiding us through each
step that you took to get to the final
result and then lastly I think we had
some talk about the About section in
your footer and your about page I think
if you're able to go a little bit more
deep on your about page and just tell me
a little bit more of your
goals or what you're aspiring to do I
think this is a perfect opportunity to
do that here but we're all really good
work
all right everyone so we've reviewed a
ton of portfolios and we've given you
advice all around so this is the time of
the episode where we're going to do a
bit of a recap so that it's very crystal
clear to you guys how you can apply
these to your portfolio so that you can
go out there and crush it in the real
world
I think tip number one context context
context context is king because it
frames the viewers eye whether this is a
potential employer or somebody who is
considering hiring you it gives them a
sense of what they're looking at and why
some of you have missed opportunities to
give these moments of context and other
view have done very well but I think
context is very important so that we
know how to evaluate what we're looking
at so we're really asking for written
statements that either can be in the
beginning of a project or in the
beginning and then captioning other
images in the project who is it for
where does it exist what is the nature
of the business and why should we care I
would also add you could put in the
context how we should look at that from
your perspective as to what you think
this represents about you the best I'd
like you to look at my experimental
typography or I used my imagery in in
this to show how I am both a designer
and an illustrator so next thing is
consistency I think consistency is very
important so when we land on your
website is there at least three to five
examples that shows consistent
professional work because if it's all
over a place maybe you might have one
really good piece in the top-left and
then we go to the bottom right your very
last piece and it's not that good you
might as well just edit that thing out
it's nice to have a couple of really
solid consistent examples so that me as
the employer we can develop trust in you
as a potential person to hire on our
team I want to encourage you if you
don't have let's say six complete
finished projects maybe you can put a
section that is projects and that has
three or four and then put a separate
section on your
website that says experiments or studies
and in there you can put these things
that are fairly unfinished or more
spontaneous and will appreciate them as
these unfinished pieces and experiments
so the next thing I think some of you
are under estimating the power of
sequence and I think sequence is very
important from the moment somebody gets
your email that you send out to them
when they land on your site to going
into your projects and then digging out
to see how the story of the project
unfolds to somebody else so it's very
important to have a clear context
upfront an overview and as you dig
deeper into any particular project you
have to hold the person's hand to guide
them through your thought process how
you identified the problem the users and
how you solve that in your design
solution you have empathy for us when
you're using acronyms or things that you
might be familiar with we don't know we
don't know what XYZ is so help us out
right right just make it clear next
thing I think patrulla landed on this a
couple of times I think it's a nice
opportunity with your portfolio's in
your work to share your unique POV I
think it's important because there are
so many designers out there looking for
a work why should I hire you over
someone else what is the unique thing
that you're gonna bring to the work and
is that clear to me now when you make
that unique point of view it may be
something that is more important to me
than it might be to Matthew but at least
we'll understand how to place you within
the context of our different design
offices and I'm not talking style I'm
really talking a unique approach to the
work that you're doing and you're a
unique combination of skills that you'll
be able to bring to the project I heard
a couple of things I heard that you want
somebody to have a wide range of skills
but then also somebody to have a unique
POV because I'm reading it a different
way than maybe the way that you're
describing it so when I think of unique
POV which I also think is important when
you have your own voice in the work I'll
give you an example if we had Jonah
shoot an event
and then we have Ricky our other editor
videographer shoot the same event their
footage are probably gonna look very
different in terms of what they found
valuable from that particular event so
that's literally their POV from their
camera their lens and how they choose to
document that and we can craft very
different stories based off at the same
exact breech or the same exact content
right so if an example here is I'm going
to rebrand this lock system like what is
your POV on that what is your take and
how did you connect the dots that's
interesting from your POV that another
designer might not have done and I think
that's why it's really important to
share that thought process and and that
POV on things I don't know that were
that we're thinking that differently
right okay another tip here that I want
to highlight for you all is that it's
very important to have a clear goal so
as you're sending your portfolio's out
if you have a clear goal of what you
want to be doing and your portfolio is
representative of that then you know how
to talk about the work in a very clear
and direct way so that me as the
employer on the other side who has
limited time to evaluate potential
candidates I know that I could take this
square peg and put it in the square hole
because that's how I'm thinking I'm
looking for a designer who's very
skilled at typography so I need to see
that in the work right so it just needs
to be very clear when you present your
work and what it is that you want to do
and what you're good at that that needs
to be represented across your portfolio
you have the opportunity to talk about
your goals in the about me statement or
in a Behance
form you can just put it as the
description on the bottom its it
shouldn't be sort of vague and general
it should be really specific I'm I'm
really interested in working with
cultural institutions doing brand
identity development and exhibition
design so be really clear about what you
want so we know how this person is a
specialist yeh it's what I want right be
very clear about your specialization
whether that's in a niche market or a
specialization in skills either way make
it clear to us so that we could place
you and you'll improve your chances of
getting work if you're looking for a job
job versus just some freelance work
there should be something on your side
that links to a resume and that resume
can be part of the website itself or it
could be a link to a PDF file the PDF
file works really well because people
sometimes print those out and stack them
up and evaluate them as a group I think
a resume is extremely important it
should be well-written extremely like
meticulous in spelling and grammar so I
think it's important I like to see where
people have gone to school I'd like to
see some of the experiences they've had
even if those experiences aren't related
to design I like to see what you're you
declare your digital expertise at if you
have some analog or craft skills if you
if you speak more than one language and
what some of the interests are you that
you have that really are relevant to the
way you approach design I have a
completely different take I don't
believe in resumes and I almost rarely
look at resumes when I hire people but I
think it's industry specific so if
you're going to let's say at Google I
believe resumes are probably pretty well
what happens at companies that are
different than then then blind or the
future is that your work is looked at by
the human resources of group okay so a
resume is super important if your resume
doesn't pass the portfolio isn't
actually given to the creative director
or director at all so you have to
separate audiences if you're going
in-house it's really important that you
are really looking at the HR manager
what they're looking for it's different
than what a creative director would be
looking for right and you've got to have
both audiences in mind if you're
interested in that kind of a comment
right and it will be very clear for you
if there's a prompt out there for a
request for a particular type of
employee or freelancer they will tell
you what the requirements are so you
just have to read the requirements very
clearly to show what it is you need to
provide as evidence that you can do the
job so sometimes it's as little as a
portfolio sometimes it's more like a
cover letter resume and portfolio
because you have to go through those
layers did you like today's episode and
do you want more of
help us out by leaving a timestamp
comment below and identify some of the
things that you guys were liking from
this particular episode were there any
tips or particular reviews that you like
this helps us shape a future content so
we deliver more value to you guys if you
need extra help developing your
portfolio and making it stand out in the
market check out the resources I left in
the description below and as always
don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe it really helps us out we'll
see you guys in the future
[Music]